shit's creek one of the sweetest shows
on television has sadly come to an
end after six remarkable seasons the
brainchild of dan levy and his father
comedy legend eugene levy this heartfelt
hilarious show was an instant classic
right out of the gate
no wonder the rose family is a truly
unforgettable bunch
eugene levy plays johnny rose the often
flummoxed businessman father
dan levy plays his endlessly anxious son
david rose
then there's the eccentric matriarch
moira played by the legendary catherine
o'hara
and let's not forget david's spoiled but
entirely lovable sister alexis played by
annie murphy
after the family's video store empire
crumbles beneath them
and leaves them penniless the family is
forced to relocate to the town of shit's
creek
which they once purchased as a joke many
of the show's earlier episodes revealed
that the roses were highly dissatisfied
with their newly modest way of life
every member of the rose family
eventually warms to their circumstances
even though they're cooped up in
adjoining rooms at the rundown rosebud
motel
in the pitch perfect finale the levees
and the cast and crew of shit's creek
let audiences say goodbye to the family
in one final surprisingly moving episode
most of the sixth and final season of
shit's creek was leading up to a big
wedding
well in the final episode david and his
loving fiance patrick
played by noah reed finally tie the knot
almost immediately the proceedings hit a
major snag
a storm hit the town and was expected to
last all day
sadly david prioritized an outdoor pizza
oven
over a tent and since the officiant he
hired only travels by penny farthing the
wedding has no venue and no one to
preside over it
since everyone else is too emotional to
handle the ceremony
moira steps up to the challenge
meanwhile patrick and ever sarcastic
stevie played by emily hampshire work to
find a wedding venue
oh and patrick arranges a massage for
david which comes with
an extra surprise after securing the
town hall for the ceremony patrick and
stevie return to find david
in an uncharacteristically good mood and
right away he thanks patrick for booking
him such an
unforgettable massage that was the first
time i have
ever received a happy ending
sir what did you just say horrified
patrick says that definitely
wasn't part of the plan then he realizes
something
asking the masseuse to treat david well
and leaving an envelope of cash may have
sent the wrong message
thankfully this raunchy rub down doesn't
turn into some big drama
thanks to patrick's understanding
attitude and david's freewheeling
sexuality
the wedding is still very much on
ultimately the wedding goes perfectly
despite the fact that alexis walks david
down the aisle in a wedding dress
apparently the fact that it came with a
tulle headdress didn't faze her
this is not a wedding dress it's a white
floor-length gown it's very different
moira dressed as the pope in a long
blonde wig
delivers a touching and tearful ceremony
and just in case you weren't crying
already
david and patrick deliver an emotional
set of vows in a nod to the first time
patrick told david that he loves him
he sings mariah carey acapella while
david tells patrick that he's never felt
so
safe and loved and that is truly his
happy ending
cut to the next morning it's time for
everyone to part ways
after a sleepless night celebrating the
wedding moira and johnny set off for
california
moira is poised to resume her role on
sunrise bay the soap opera that made her
a star
meanwhile alexis is set to head to new
york and patrick and david will remain
in shit's creek in their new house
it's a truly emotional goodbye it feels
like the actors and
characters are simultaneously offering
tearful farewells to people in places
they truly love
moira and johnny set off stopping for
one last look at the vaguely obscene
town sign that has been repainted to
depict the rose family themselves
and that's that don't be too sad after
finishing this tear-jerker of a finale
after all you can stream the first five
seasons of shit's creek on netflix
right now and start the story all over
again the full
sixth season should be available for
streaming later this year
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one